Callbacks are the default JavaScript
technique for asynchronous work.
Pass the function to another function,
and then call
the callback function at some later
time when some conditions have been met.
This works well but there are some
questions without obvious answers.
For instance, how do you handle errors?
It's best practice to assume that any
operation could fail at any time.
It's doubly important to assume so
with network requests.
If an error occurs here,
should you still execute the call back?
If so, what value should it receive?
If not, then what should happen?
What if it's a JavaScript error?
Should that be handled any
differently than a network error?
There's no clear answer.
Node basically makes error
first callbacks mandatory but
that doesn't really solve the problem.
It's still basically your job to define,
and
implement an error handling strategy.
Assume that everything happened
just fine, no errors and
then this callback runs when
the onload handler gets called.
Great.
Now you've chained together
two pieces of work, but
what if this callback is also
an asynchronous operation and
you need something else
to happen afterwards?
Do you pass another function
with another callback here?
This is one scenario that leads to
something called the Pyramid of Doom.
A dreadful situation
where there are nasty,
nasty nested callbacks within
call backs, within callbacks.
This looks ugly and
it's hard to write, but
the real sin is that it is
incredibly frustrating to debug.
This is the same kind of code, but
written with promises,
and my, it looks nicer.
You'll be learning all about the beauty
of .then later in this course.
For now, just read this and appreciate
the fact that you can figure out what's
happening here, despite the fact that
you haven't even finished this course.
That's pretty awesome.